i think compatibility is so important so
would you tell a young woman to sleep
around and like explore their sexuality
or would you tell them to keep your body
count as low as possible so you can get
the best quality husband
um
i would say what what is important to
you
and some people that's it some people
see some people sleep around for
validation and then i'd be like don't do
that right don't do that like please
like don't do that like i have had
casual sex because i enjoy sex
that's the right long and short of it i
enjoy sex
um
female sexual liberation i'm all here
for it yeah um but i used to be very
codependent because it was all dependent
upon my self-worth was dependent upon
being desirable to a man and i got to a
point in like late 2020 where i was like
i don't want to do that anymore because
i've either been undervalued or
underappreciated and i ended up in
relationships where i thought the men
were my league
but they didn't respect me so then i
dated men who were under my league who
adored me and then i was like you're not
enough
well do you yeah do you think maybe they
were actually your league because like
you can't say that someone was your
league if they weren't able to commit to
you like your league is who you can get
to commit to you but then this comes to
the success and ambition and blah blah
blah right but remember men and women
are valued for different things yeah so
oh i settled for men that were short and
broke i settled for men but they could
say like they settled for you with a
high body count but they could they
could say the same thing but they are
men that literally the men that i
settled for were men that literally were
like they look at me in the morning and
be like you're the most beautiful person
in the world and i was like no i'm not
you're correct i you i was like you
literally you expect too too little i
got you some some behavior i got you
it's different behavior
yeah like
i was gonna say i think there is a i
think there is a middle yeah between um
between
uh a girl getting a guy
because i get what you're saying yeah
like
for for girls your league isn't who you
can sleep with your league is who you
can get who can get to commit to you but
what i would say is that a lot of girls
date guys who could have committed to
them but because they've dated them in a
certain way they've put themselves in
the friends of benefit zone so now
that's not
on the table does that make sense so i
think there is like you know for sure
like there is like a you know like oh if
a guy's a nine and he's sleeping with a
girl who's quoting quite a five that
she's probably never gonna commit to her
right but it's possible that okay for
guys and eight who gets a lot of
attention he may sleep with a girl as an
a but if she
plays it wrong he might think oh she's
hot
like she's very attractive because she's
not girlfriend i think guys go down and
looks all the time i'm not like disney
but just sex yeah i'm not discounting
that but what i'm saying like as a girl
it's still what you can get to commit
because that's still you it's your it's
your choices yeah right it's true but i
think i think girls don't um
i think a lot of girls
do date guys who could have committed to
them mm-hmm it's just because the way
they dated them the guy was like well
she's not girlfriend material yeah and
then this does come back to body count
because i've had an experience where
recently a guy is like well i've not
dated anyone since you i get a bit
jealous when you tell me you want to end
things and i'm like you've told me
you're not gonna commit to me you're not
gonna be serious about me i'm never
gonna be your girlfriend i'm like but
you are serious about me and to be fair
body count doesn't actually relate to
our situation
but
oh there's just so many like
really like intricate details and it's
not it's not necessarily like practical
in this day and age right because again
the average age of first marriage is 27.
like guys used to marry virgins and now
like guys don't even like want virgins
yeah but that's it it's that whole
whole black and white situation where a
guy you know
a lot of it's about ego and a lot of it
yeah a lot of it is about people's
self-worth and self-esteem
and i did have a really good point to
say oh it's about um attractiveness even
that so i
used to go off of the ethos to a blind
person we all look the same so i gave a
lot of people chances and i used to go
on dates with anyone because i just
don't do that i'm like don't don't don't
do it this sounds so awful but like so i
did that i was like what are you gonna
do give them pity sex like
i used to pity i
i used to pity kiss people i give people
my phone number and be like i don't
really want to give you my phone but
maybe
if you're showing me interest
and a guy so this is why i say
undervalued or underwhelmed yeah so that
was what i ended up in i used to be like
guys that i thought were like my level
my league would like not value me
and then guys that were who really
adored me loved me really valued me i
was like oh you're underwhelming i don't
think that you might drop and that's why
i've been single single by choice for a
year and a half because i'm like i don't
want to get hurt i don't i don't want to
hurt anyone but i don't get hurt and i
was like i'm actually you're also you're
being alone you're also competing for a
small percentage of guys too that you're
probably attracted you know that only
like ten percent i don't even i don't
know the exact stat but
i've heard numbers from five to fifteen
percent of dating app swipes are i don't
use dating apps i don't use any data
absolutely no and it's because dating
apps do tend to be a black and white
party in that you've either got people
on there who are like i just want
something casual nice not nothing
serious
um or you've got people who are like i'm
looking for a relationship so you've got
two types of processing you've got top
down or bottom up top down processing
and people who are like i want a
relationship ergo i am looking for
someone who can fill that criteria so
when they go on dates when they swipe
they're like i'm literally thinking
about
are you going to be relational material
or
there's people like me i'm bottom up
where i'm like i'd rather just meet
someone and be like
where is this going to go let's live in
there now let's take it date by date
time but do you think that women it
would be better for women if we dated
more intentionally because to me it's
like if you could be single you could be
single let's say you're single for five
years you're in a relationship for five
years
like i would think that the girl would
probably be less like
heartbroken and have less trauma if she
was in a relationship for five years
because i mean assuming he's not
narcissist assuming assuming there's no
abuse narcissism like any of that stuff
because if you're just like dating
around like like i don't know like at
some point you're gonna get rejected by
guys that like don't call you back or
like you know what i'm saying like [ __ ]
like that happens all the time
better is subjective like eat pray love
is based on a real life story where
she's she's married she's successful
yeah she's like i'm actually not happy
i'm actually not like to circle back
with that lady yeah that turned out
yeah
and it's like
there are people who sometimes wake up
and go [ __ ] i'm not happy and i should
be happy i hate the concept of should
and so i'm a really big advocate for
like difference do you do you think
happiness like comes and goes oh yeah
like like do you think you should just
leave a relation a relationship with
like kids and stuff if you're not happy
so i was gonna i was gonna say would you
here's a question would you sacrifice
happiness for fulfillment
yeah
would you because i think happened like
say happiness can go up and down yeah
like it's an emotion right it comes it's
not happiness isn't a
permanent state that you can be in but
you can be content and fulfilled what
you have but we just sacrifice happiness
for fulfillment
then it depends like for me
happiness
is probably
oh no to be fair happiness isn't
dependent on fulfillment but i'm always
over the i was like we could die
tomorrow and if you're not happy and if
you're not like content if you're not if
you're not a whole
individual
then anything else that you like put
yourself into like
i don't know it's a really tough lesson
nothing is ever like that's it going
back to nothing is black and white right
or wrong better or worse
um
nothing's right or wrong but like it's
that gray area of like in some
situations i'd probably be like
i'll sacrifice happiness for like even
when you study or you you do a job if
you do a job through your interesting i
think if you ask men the same question
most of them would say yes i think women
care a lot more about being happy and
men care a lot more about being
fulfilled well that's like because i
think i think it's not about like you
especially if you have a family it's not
about you anymore like doesn't she leave
does she leave a husband and kids and
eat pray love
uh she leaves her husband i have kids
my husband did a job yeah like i don't
know i think that's that's a bit selfish
you're leaving a commitment you made for
what to go like go to india but to be
selfish means that we're prioritizing
what everyone else wants compared to
what we want yeah but sometimes what you
want isn't right like emotions come and
go people leave that's it right and
wrong very subjective there's it's it's
all about that gray area walking the
middle path right and wrong to one
person so that's it genocide and racism
to one person is right uh-huh like
things to one person are correct and you
could argue until you're blue in the
face and be like that's not correct and
they literally be like like that's it
hitler hitler literally what is she
it's not even right
i think there's consequences and i i i'd
really like to circle back with that
later maybe she made a book she made a
lot of money it might have worked out
yeah yeah yeah yeah she made bang
because yeah so you know what i mean
maybe she did but i don't think the
average woman that makes that decision
it's going to end up well for her no no
not at all and that's why you've got to
be cognizant of differences and
privileges and
circumstances and things like that so
yeah the average woman could not be like
i'm not happy in my job or my marriage
or being a mum yeah because then you're
like well [ __ ]
finances your your marriage your family
like your kids and the average woman
could not do that
um but does it mean that she shouldn't
want to or she like it's just like uh
but then you get stuck
being like are you living for yourself
or are you living for others are you
living for expectations i think it's
okay
i think it's okay to live for others and
i'll give you an example okay yeah i
live a lot for my dad's approval like a
lot i care a lot what my dad thinks like
a lot and i do a lot of things not
because i want to but because he wants
me to and i don't mean like like i would
i'm doing this clearly because i love
this yeah he doesn't care about social
media but just in terms of like like my
last boyfriend my dad didn't like and
that really bothered me it bothered me a
lot because i love my dad and i think
like there's some things it's okay
it's almost a good thing to like put you
know values and like your commitments
and like your word above what makes you
happy at the time yeah i i was gonna say
i think the difference between people
today and people back in the day is that
we back in the day people all about
community yeah it was all about doing
what's best for the community it was all
about doing what's best for your family
whereas now
i think
i think back then we didn't have enough
individualism that people were
sacrificing a lot of their happiness for
their community but now we've gone the
other way where there's so much
individualism now yeah that people are
no longer contributing or even care
about their local community or their
family and their nuclear family which is
why people leave
et cetera et cetera so i i agree and
you know i'm my family nigerian and in
our culture like once you have kids it's
about them you do what's best for them
so
if you but you staying with your partner
is what's best for the kids and you can
make that work that's what you do until
they leave then you split up or whatever
i actually i always say people always
ask me if i'd stay with the cheater and
i always say no unless
there were kids
interesting why'd you say that because
if they're kids it's not about me
how about you
um i mean i've i've stayed with jesus
i've stayed producers and i know a lot
of that is actually based upon my
self-worth and being like you know xyz
and i'd love to say no i know i deserve
better and no no but yeah if there's
kids it's a whole different ballpark and
if you're it depends on how selfish
yourself because being selfish isn't a
bad thing because if you're like well
i'm living for others then when do you
live for you because
and it oh it really depends on like so a
lot of people love honor and pride so
you don't think being selfish is a bad
thing so no no so you say you live for
your dad's approval my dad's a piece of
[ __ ] yeah that's a piece of [ __ ] my
family
we are not close at all my mom literally
had been like me like right
and so i'm like if i'm not living for me
and enjoying my life i could be dead
tomorrow and if i knew that i lived for
everyone else i'm living for their
approval or my well-being and my quality
of life is dependent upon how they feel
towards me yeah and if that's it it's
not black and white it's very much like
the people i love
know that i love them the people i love
i'm i'm very much a i want you to feel
loved i want you but then i'm like
i've done a lot of therapy and so
they're like hey amy you can only feel
good about yourself when you think
others feel good about you and they're
like that's really
so your self-worth is dependent upon the
approval of others i think that's normal
well if everyone hates you there's
probably a reason well
as far as i'm aware no one has ever
hated me but i've been so i stayed with
the cheetah because yeah i've said with
many teachers and i
i've been in a relationship that was
the most toxic thing that i've ever
imagined that everyone in my life is
like we don't he still talks to me and i
still haven't we broke up three
four years ago we still have an open
communication path because i can't block
people because i'm like i feel really
bad if i block them even if they're
toxic for me and they're worse i can't
block them
i can't i can't do it that's it i can't
do it and everyone is like amy like are
you confused this person was awful to
you disrespected you and you still feel
the need to be good for them good for
their approval
and i'm just like
ah because it makes you feel like bad
person where black people